>>> THE FAA
LAUNCHING AN INVESTIGATION AFTER
TWO PLANES NEARLY COLLIDED ON
THE RUNWAY.
ONE PLANE ABOUT TO TAKEOFF,
ANOTHER CROSSING IN FRONT OF IT.
PETE MUNTEAN JOINS ME NOW.
THINK ABOUT IT ALL THE TIME,
ESPECIALLY AT BUSY AIRPORTS.
HOW DID IT GET THIS CLOSE?
>> Reporter: SECONDS TO SPARE
BUT THE GOOD NEWS IS THIS WAS
AVOIDED THANKS TO THE QUICK
THINKING OF THE AIR TRAFFIC
CONTROLLER IN THE TOWER AT JFK
AND THE QUICK REACTION BY THE
DELTA CREW ON BOARD THE 737.
THIS IS THE ANIMATION FROM
FLIGHT RADAR 24.
YOU CAN SEE THE DELTA FLIGHT
THERE WAS ABOUT TO TAKEOFF ON
RUNWAY 4 LEFT THERE AT JFK WHEN
AN AMERICAN AIRLINES FLIGHT
CROSSED IN FRONT OF IT.
LISTEN TO THE URGENCY BY THE AIR
TRAFFIC CONTROLLER IN THE TOWER
WARNING THE CREW OF THAT DELTA
FLIGHT TO SLAM ON THE BRAKES AND
STOP TO MAKE SURE THEY DON'T HIT
THAT OTHER PLANE TAXIING ACROSS
THE RUNWAY.
>> DELTA, 1943, CANCEL TAKEOFF
PLANS.
DELTA 1943 CANCEL TAKEOFF PLANS.
>> REJECTING.
>> Reporter: THE FAA SAYS ABOUT
1,000 FEET OF SEPARATION BETWEEN
THE TWO PLANES IN THE END.
SOUNDS LIKE A LOT BUT IT'S ABOUT
THREE FOOTBALL FIELDS BUT PRETTY
CLOSE IN AVIATION TERMS.
THIS IS A RUN WAY INCURSION.
THESE HAPPEN ALL THE TIME
ACCORDING TO THE FAA, 1600 OF
THEM IN 2022, TYPICALLY NOT AS
DRAMATIC AS THIS ONE, ALTHOUGH
THE CONSEQUENCES ARE WRITTEN IN
BLOOD, THE DISASTER IN 1977, TWO
747s HIT EACH OTHER ON THE
RUNWAY.
500 PEOPLE KILLED, THE SINGLE
WORST AIRPLANE CLASH IN AVIATION
HISTORY, POPPY.
>> THAT DELTA PILOT, CALM.
>> VERY CALM.
CAN I ASK YOU SOMETHING PETE.
THE DELTA PLANE WAS ABOUT TO
TAKE OFF.
WAS IT GAINING MOMENTUM OR WAS
IT THE BEGINNING OF THE TAXI?
>> Reporter: THEY WERE
ACCELERATING FOR TAKEOFF.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT PILOTS
PRACTICE ALL THE TIME IN THE
SIMULATOR.
THEY'RE TYPICALLY NOT OFTEN
CONFRONTED WITH IT IN REAL LIFE.
SO THEY WERE JUST ABOUT BEFORE
THE SPEED THAT YOU NEED TO
TAKEOFF, YOU HAVE TO COMMIT AT A
CERTAIN POINT SO ONCE YOU HIT
THE SPEED YOU HAVE TO KEEP
FLYING.
THEY DID NOT GET THERE JUST YET
SO THEY WERE ABLE TO STOP AND
DECELERATE.
STOP BEFORE THE 777 STILL ON THE
RUNWAY.
LET'S DISCUSS WITH FORMER
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION
INSPECTOR, MARY SCIAVO.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO THIS?
>> IT'S NOT MY REACTION.
WHAT HAPPENED HERE FALLS INTO
THE MOST SERIOUS CATEGORY OF
RUNWAY INCURSIONS, AND THEY
DIVIDE THEM UP THROUGH THE
SERIOUSNESS OF A, B, C AND D,
AND THIS IS THE TOP, THIS IS THE
MOST SERIOUS.
THERE ARE ABOUT 20 OF THESE MOST
SERIOUS CATEGORIES, A AND B
EVERY YEAR, AND THE MORE
DISTURBING STATISTIC, RUNWAY
IN
INCURSIONS HAVE BEEN UP 92% FROM
2011 UNTIL 2018.
SO THIS IS A HUGE ISSUE WITH THE
GOVERNMENT, WITH THE FAA AND MY
OLD OFFICE, THE OFFICE OF
INSPECTOR GENERAL.
THIS IS ONE STATISTIC ON THE
RISE AND IT'S NOT A STATISTIC
YOU WANT TO SEE RISE.
IT'S A PROBLEM.
>> WHY IS IT ON THE RISE?
>> WELL, MANY REASONS.
I MEAN, OBVIOUSLY AVIATION HAS
INCREASED OVER THE YEARS, BUT
THE STUDIES HAVE LOOKED INTO WHY
THIS IS OCCURRING BLAME MANY
DIFFERENT THINGS.
THERE HAVE BEEN MANY KINDS OF
DIFFERENT EQUIPMENT AND MANY
PROGRAMS THE FAA PROPOSED.
THEY PUT SOME FORTH, AND ONE WAS
CALLED A-MASS, AND IT WAS
NICKNAMED AMASS, AND IT WAS
SCRAPPED AND NOW THEY USE
DETECTION EQUIPMENT AND THEY ARE
WORKING ON SPECIALIZED RUNWAY
LIGHTING TO GIVE PILOTS AND AIR
TRAFFIC CONTROLLERS CLUES AS TO
WHEN THERE'S AN INTERSECTION.
A LOT OF THESE PROGRAMS HAVE
BEEN ON DEVELOPMENT A LONG TIME.
NOT ALL OF THE AIRCRAFT ARE
EQUIPPED WITH THEM.
AIRCRAFT CARRIERS ARE EQUIPPED
WITH THE MOST MODERN EQUIPMENT,
AND MOST RUNWAY INCURSIONS,
ABOUT 60%, OCCUR AT TOWERED
AIRPORTS, AIRPORTS WITH A TOWER.
YOU WOULD THINK THEY WOULD
HAPPEN AT NON-TOWERED AIRPORTS.
THIS IS A PROBLEM THAT HAS BEEN
ON THE RADAR SCREEN, AND IT'S A
STATISTIC THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT
TRYING TO BRING DOWN.
THIS WAS THE MOST SERIOUS
CATEGORY OF ALL.
>> REALLY ALARMING.
MARY, THANK YOU.